je m'appelle tokyo
mais ce n'était pas mon nom quand toute
cette histoire a commencé maman je crois
bien que je vais m'offrir un voyage
personne n'avait jamais monté un peu
pareil ni à new york ni à londres où
elle la montée vers le haut et qui est à
avoir à nouveau ma photo dans les
journaux
autant que ce soit pour le plus gros
casse telle histoire
chaque famille de ce pays pauvres à la
même question qu'est ce qu'il est
possible ou quoi
la fabrique nationale de la monniais
il est fondamental que la police ne
compte absolument pas de ce qu'on
prépare mais il faudra faire très
attention si jamais il y a une seule
équipe a dit au revoir à notre image de
robin des bois locaux devient simplement
une forte chaleur nous faire confiance
et nous avait dit qu'une 2e et 3e tenez
vous prêtes mais cette quiétude annoncé
le calme avant la tempête
tout allait tellement partir en proue
vous passerez à deux doigts de perdre la
partie de bollinger
je suis devenue tueuse